hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute wieder ein spiel das vom alter her
genau auf mich angepasst ist
bibi und tina sammle die hufeisen
hufeisen sind echte glücksbringer man
kann nie genug davon haben hilft bibi
und tina und sammler so viele
glücksbringer wie möglich gut wir
klicken einfach mal los und das ist ja
eine ganz schön krass anleitung hier
diese gegenstände musst du einsammeln
ein hufeisen zehn punkte blumen bringen
fünf punkte und 1 stern es einen
zeitbonus dass es auf zeit diese
gegenstände musste überspringen benutze
zum springen die space taste auf der
tastatur
ich weiß nicht ob ich mir das alles
merken kann um nach rechts und links zu
laufen benutze die pfeiltasten spiel
starten okay das heißt ich zocke bibi
und tina sammle die hufeisen und bin ich
habe zeit ich muss auf zeit
das war super du hast null punkte
aber auch mal ein bisschen schneller
unterwegs bringt das war richtig knapp
noch schön hier die hufeisen hier die
blümchen was es ist das hier
rotter fock ich will mit meinem kopf um
eine zeitgenössische herunter wenn ich
hier drin bin meine zeit geht eh schon
doppelt so schnell runter dass
schließlich doch verarscht 430 sekunde
aber derzeit alle zwei sekunden dass man
kann doch nicht wahr sein kommen hier
vorne schneller verweisen und jetzt den
zeit bundes sammeln jetzt zählt auf
einmal wieder automatisch richtig
kombiniert das ist nein wie wir
oh mein gott das ist nicht wahr ich hab
grad zum springen die fall dass nach
oben gedrückt
das geht auch gab's nur getestet und das
sagen die mir jetzt erst sie benutze zum
springen die skater den renntag
vielleicht doch die fans nach oben
das baby das ist der sinn von diesem
spiel ich stehe vor dem block
da da zeitpunkt modus kommt weiter müsse
man laut über die heuballen drüber dann
hier eine blume hier das turnier sei
daher und dann wieder ab in die wüste
hier die blumen daran zeitnot und ihr
laub blumen blumen wie soll ich denn
hier jetzt ich kann ja ich kann ja durch
die steilen durch springen war mein gott
apoll heilige schein was genau heißt es
wenn ich im wasser bin da passiert doch
nicht mehr oder um eine punkte gehen
runter juni das machen gemacht dass sie
die ganze zur demonstration was passiert
wenn ich ins wasser fallen man lebt
springen noch einmal hand sein dass das
ein endlosspiel ist und einfach wenn die
zeit vorbei ist ist es vorbei mal guckt
dann wie viele punkte ich einfach in der
zeit geschafft weil immer weniger zeit
boni com oder irre ich mich da gerade
bei der komplexität dieses spiel läuft
aber auch elegant alter das ist ja
wundervoll und dann springt die wieder
wie so ein komischer affe mama jetzt
hier dass wir noch einen zeitbonus
kriegen vielleicht und dann ist jetzt
auch hier ist
ich hab dich mein ziel gesehen aber ich
wäre ja nicht luca wenn ich nicht noch
den zweiten teil davon spielen will ich
halte meine fresse das hier ist sammle
die hufeisen teil 2 und wir die kamera
geht sogar mit baby mit alta badia
bewegt sich sogar was ist denn das jetzt
dieses level ist einerseits weisen
sammelt zwei andererseits habe ich auch
dezent mehr zeit gerade um mein gott
mein essen ist gerade angekommen man es
nicht angekommen ganz gut denke ich
lasse
vielleicht 80 sekunden sehe ich sehe ich
bin jetzt viel zu hell dass wir in den
nächsten zehn minuten finde ich also ich
habe nur 60 sekunden gebrochen das essen
von der tür zu holen ihn als tasten wehe
jemand reicht bei akinator
nein ich sage mir einfach nichts mit dem
jetzt einfach auch so fucking viele
youtuber irgendwie akinator machen habe
ich mir als ob ich da einfach an hoch
gesprungen bin hatte ich mir gedacht
dass ich mir mal so ein anderes spiel
suche ich hatte ja irgendwie clever bot
dann gemacht dann hatte das irgendwie
hatten dass relativ viele gibt das ist
denn dieses level hat 1000 ebenen also
eher zeitlicher clever bord was ich sehr
oft hochgeladen hatte dann hatten
deshalb sehr viele andere auch gemacht
hat wollte ich das wieder nicht mehr
machen jetzt ist es halt mit akinator so
die sache und ich hätte jetzt halt voll
gern auch da sind diamanten roboter vor
ich hätte halt voll bock das wir wieder
zusammenkommen spiel finden so ähnlich
wie akinator oder klappert oder siri
mäßig so in etwa wo man so fragen
stellen kann irgendwie sowas ich hatte
überlegt ob ich will mal zu machen das
ist quasi so chatroulette und cooler
also chatroulette ist ja an sich
eigentlich wirklich eine ganz coole
sache nur ich will nicht 100 hochladen
weil man hat keine rechte an den ganzen
leuten die man da zeigt es sind meist es
nur komische verwirrte menschen
herumlaufen und irgendwie keine ahnung
stellt euch mal vor dass ein dickes
mädel und er hat einfach so totale
probleme mit ihrem körper und nein ich
bin die ganze zeit im wasserlauf baby
lauf einfach durchs wasser durch und ich
bin wieder komplett am start
alles klar also dass mit chatroulette
mal eben zu ende zu bringen dann das
möchte ich ungern hochladen wenn er dann
so menschen sind die wirklich fertig
sind und dann kommen youtuber an und
lachen sich darüber kaputt das kann ich
dann das will ich nicht vertreten da bin
ich traurig dass ich solche leute kenne
diese wasser hochladen und dann will ich
einfach nicht oracle wiederum kann ich
sagen dass ich ein hashtag einführend da
könnten nur ihr darunter john und da
sind dann keine komischen jetzt ist das
spiel tatsächlich vorbei ich hoffe er
hat verstanden dass oracle so in etwa
ist also das hatte ich mal gedacht
hochzuladen weil mittlerweile die nato
und abbott ist sind es gibt viel zu viel
videos auf youtube wehrt euch dieses
spiel gefallen hat dann zeigt es mir mit
einem alles klar